ein lebenszeichen nein nein nein wir
machen
ich weiß wie ich zum schreiben kriege
ich fange mit der angel ab
auf jeden fall da kann ich das
korrigiert
safer sex kids und herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video spielen heute
jopling auf level tt.com sollte ich
eigentlich wissen und max ist wieder
dabei wenn mal wieder eine richtig coole
challenge und zwar eine von six oder
speed six und die lautet streber
challenge heißt wir müssen am ende jedes
moduls in den chats schreiben dass wir
das modul abgeschlossen haben und jeden
korrigieren der etwas in den chats
schreibt und dabei rechtschreibfehler
macht was ungefähr so ziemlich jede
nachricht ist so ich denke es geht jetzt
schreibe ich ich habe modul 1
abgeschlossen so gut und jetzt darf ich
erst zur nächsten wo du leute leute
glaubt mir wenn die leute ich habe
gerade eben schon mal versucht gab mit
dieser challenge und wenn die leute
irgendwann richtig genervt sind von euch
schreiben so höher du idiot was
schreibst du dafür eine chance und so
nervös ich und du musst sie jedes mal
korrigieren erachtet bei minecraft schon
auf korrekte schreibweise also du gehst
ja alles groß und kleinschreibung was
natürlich besonders wichtig ist für dich
naja ritschel
von daher ist es schon die sache und sie
beschreibt mit satzzeichen in minecraft
niemand all diese dinge das muss ich
alles korrigieren als wenn jemand
falsche satzzeichen verwendet wenn
jemand auch kommt perfekt richtig
scheint aber ein komma vergisst muss den
ganzen satz unterschreiben mit komma
okay ich bin heute der der deutschlehrer
sehr sehr penibler deutschlehrer und
jetzt hier
ok er beschwert sich nur keine bisher
beschwert sich keiner was ich ziemlich
cool finde ich jetzt schon längst
geflucht hat und längst gesagt ja was
ist los mit dir
in schweren geistigen schaden dort ist
momentan noch cool leute zurück
sorry gut dass du dabei sitzt alter sehr
wichtig man momentan sind die leute echt
noch fair mit mir also wie gesagt ich
hätte schon längst ausgerottet deswegen
kann ich auch verstehen wenngleich eine
herbe beleidigung kommt welche
auseinandernehmen nähe aber ich werde
sie brecht schrank korrigieren weil die
mit sicherheit falsch geschrieben und
wird auf ja ich werde die fotografisch
dekonstruieren
ok niemand schreibt was es sein segen
niemand schreibt was dort vielleicht
auch dass das bild bisschen heller ist
welches wasser an
ja ich habe die gamma werte hoch
gestellt heisst ich hatte nicht mehr so
dunkel
dadurch kann man ja alles in allem
bisschen besser sehen wie findet ihr es
wenn ich oft komplex spiele ich mag
momentan einfach gerade eigentlich nur
jump lists spielmodus deswegen spielen
und jump blick weil ich finde es wichtig
dass man auch spaß daran hat was man was
man macht sowieso auf youtube deswegen
spielt momentan eher nur jump league wie
ist es bei euch denkt ihr euch ja cool
job ich schaue ich mir auch gerne an
auch wenn eröffnete shopping bringt oder
nein nicht schon wieder jump league oder
york ist mir egal ich habe alles gut zu
auf oder geht wird es oder geld ja
stichwort geld gut ich hab letztes mal
meine stats geschaut das können jetzt
auch mal machen hätte ich ganz gedacht
dass ich da so weit vorne bin und zwar
stets wir sind global rang 67 also schon
mal einen top 70 der doppik spieler das
ist eigentlich ziemlich gut zählt nur
die frage wie krass dann die leute über
mir gesucht haben weil ich habe nein
nein nein ich habe wo die leute
schreiben einfach nicht in der letzten
aufnahme die fibel geschrieben das ist
voller segen
die sind einfach konzentriert du bist
auch wenig platz eins und doch bin ich
ein bisschen alte okay szenario 1 ließ
sich mega wie nickname eigentlich
vielleicht ist ein anderer youtuber auch
gerade in der runde auch gerade auf und
philipp gerade von der kuh erhält
glp das spiel angeblich auch relativ auf
job liegt aber natürlich super passen
nach der tour der geschichte so gut okay
ich habe modul 8 abgeschlossen aber ich
finds geil die leute schreiben nichts in
die knechtschaft das ist perfekt aber im
deathmatch wird ja da konnte was wir
natürlich komme ich immer abstauber oder
sowas sowie in get down immer rascher
kommt kommt in dem zimmer abstauber im
job league finale da wird nur abgestaubt
klar aber man muss lernen damit zu leben
ich rege mich auch mal auf aber ich
hoffe doch selbst ab deswegen dieselbe
sache auf die ok gut ich habe modul 09
abgeschlossen als wird gut [ __ ] sie
provozieren kommen ich will sie
korrigieren anhänger aktions störungen
dazu gibt's gehalten und alter co2 level
aber dem was ich stehe jetzt liegen
lassen und bekommen dann kannst du da
bist ich bis mitternacht in meiner
crêpes winters siebter distrikte jetzt
geht es entsprechend heute gibt es ein
trikot und sprinten
ja ja auch 321 stadt fragte neulich
musste
32 sekunden ja das war der countdown
jungen alter junge alter der classic
stock da kommt einer hatte war ich wie
ein kind beleidigen die nerven
isaac komm ich muss die leute so
provoziert wie findet ihr die shader mit
mit höherem kammer ich finde ich geil
aus sofia und im rhein kommen rein es
könnten uns kräften er man findet ihn
niemand neben dir schon eine auch nur
einmal den chat benutzt sei
er stoppt rubins rapper jay-z mann ich
will euch korrigieren leute prinzip
keiner auch nur ein witz kein einziger
eiskalte schreibt nichts die dicke la
mala keine tastatur haben spielen
vielleicht weil die davor ich glaube ich
bin allem einkauf mit controller oder
chat die hütte der zuvor beleidigt haben
nein so dass ein koffer direkt.de alter
schwede als completely noch tiefer sorge
dass davon drin und eine christoph beck
3 level wohsmann enchanted man muss man
in schalter hey du hast und vier gegner
man ihr seid voll alter ich höre die
schreiben einfach nichts das macht die
streber natürlich leicht dahinter wer
freut sich kurieren jetzt töten oder
muss jetzt korrigieren selber der punkt
aber jetzt gibt es das nur weil du ein
sucht ein hatte ein richtiges süchtiger
bist punkt punkt wichtig alter ich gehe
jetzt fuld hatte dieser ist ja und nein
da ist eine als ob er da im schatten
schild schied aus was hat er hier
ich nehme alles mit und zweiten kompass
kann nicht schaden
anthony ich musste ja leute
entschuldigung selber
er war eigentlich korrekt hatte selber
ist eigentlich umgangssprachlich heute
weitere entschuldige ich meinte du
selbst neben vorher auch die uni sie
leute man muss sagen alle
man darf nicht vergessen dass ich jetzt
einfach unglaublich glück hatte weil
einfach wär doch mal was geschrieben hat
wow und es weg so der andere johann
hatte halte ein hatte ich würde mal
sagen was muss ich sagen halte ein halte
ein ohne satzzeichen nein nein nein was
wir machen
ich weiß wie ich zum schreiben krieg ich
fange mit der angel ab
auf jeden fall das korrigiert
sechseinhalb stunden später ja wenn ich
die alle treffer eigentlich nicht und es
geht endlos so wenn ich den bug der
schreibt ja nichts schreibt doch was
in einigen jahren eine chance liegt im
rating wahrscheinlich so wenn du
aufhörst dann direkt um
aber halt nur noch ein leben ich könnte
jetzt wegklatschen
lol lol lol aber er kommt nicht ran er
kommt nicht ran und ins wasser mit ihr
all bleiben wasser wasser wasser wasser
denn ich will nicht dauernd muss
aufpassen ich könnte ja auch im fahrzeug
bis nach fakten kaum laufen
und zack
das ist alles schon hart aber ich glaube
da schreibt nicht denn der will nicht
schreiben der dlc taste ist kaputt auf
seinem tour gehört ich weiß nicht ob
regen kann einfach nicht haben wir am
ende doch was mitnehmen
er brennt nicht und leertaste kommt
nein dieses blöde gras alter dieses
blöde gras ich glaube du meintest hh
punkt vergessen wenn jetzt gewinnt ist
ganz verliebt
das lernt man daraus seid keine streber